les élections départementales sont
organisées tous les 6 ans selon un
scrutin majoritaire binominal à deux
tours ça veut dire qu'on vote pour un
binôme un homme et une femme ainsi que
leur suppléant et non pas pour une liste
ce binôme et ses suppléants représentent
un cantons c'est-à-dire un regroupement
de communes dont le chef-lieu est la
plus grande ville généralement par
exemple le canton de Mantes-la-Jolie
regroupe 5 communes et son chef-lieu et
Mantes-la-Jolie les habitants de
Mantes-la-Jolie et des quatre autres
communes voteront donc pour un binôme se
présentant dans ce canton et uniquement
dans ce canton dans les Yvelines il
existe 21 cantons donc 21 binômes
candidats au poste de conseiller
départementaux pour être élu dès le
premier tour qui aura lieu le 20 juin
prochain les binômes doivent obtenir la
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
en clair 50% des voix plus une voix de
l'ensemble des personnes votantes il
faut aussi que le nombre de suffrages
soit au moins égal à un quart des
électeurs inscrits sur le canton si un
second tour est nécessaire il faut que
les binômes est obtenu au moins 12,5% du
nombre d'électeurs inscrits dans le
canton si un seul binôme de candidats
remplit cette condition le binôme ayant
obtenu le plus grand nombre de suffrages
après lui peut se maintenir si aucun
binôme ne remplit cette condition seuls
les deux premiers peuvent se maintenir
au second tour les autres binômes eux
sont éliminés le second tour aura lieu
lui le 27 juin 2021 et là la majorité
relative suffit dernière particularité
en cas d'égalité des suffrages
l'élection est acquise au binôme qui
comporte le candidat le plus âgé